Get ready for a fast and furious dose of summer
action.
Reviews are racing in for Hobbs & Shaw, a
standalone spinoff presented by the Fast and
Furious franchise.
It's generally agreed that the film delivers
exactly what it promises: plenty of high-octane,
over-the-top set pieces, held together by
lots of witty banter and some serious chemistry
between its two leads.
"No way, this guy's a real a------"
With 102 reviews counted, the film currently
stands at a 72% average on Rotten Tomatoes.
Hobbs & Shaw finds our titular duo teaming
up to eradicate a serious threat: Brixton
Lore, portrayed by Idris Elba, is a superpowered
terrorist and self-proclaimed "black Superman"
intent on unleashing a potent virus on the
world.
"Who the hell are you?"
"Bad guy."
Back in January, star Dwayne Johnson promised
that
"[The film will be] the biggest showdown the
FAST & FURIOUS franchise has ever seen"
Well, it certainly has the right pedigree.
It was penned by Chris Morgan, the screenwriter
behind The Fast and the Furious: Tokyo Drift,
Fast & Furious, Fast Five, Fast & Furious
6, Furious 7, and The Fate of the Furious.
Suffice to say, this man knows exactly what
fans want.
Meanwhile, director David Leitch is a co-director
of the action-packed original John Wick, and
also delivered a similarly off-kilter blast
of craziness with last year's Deadpool 2.
According to critics, Leitch and company have
delivered an exciting, entertaining action
film that takes full advantage of the crackling
chemistry between Johnson and co-star Jason
Statham.
They also praised the performances by Vanessa
Kirby and Elba.
On the other hand, the film's detractors focused
on the outlandish action sequences…but what
did they expect?
Entertainment Weekly's Leah Greenblatt understands
that the bonkers action is exactly the point,
writing that,
"[Hobbs & Shaw is] a testosterone motherlode
so relentlessly, ridiculously adrenalized,
it doesn't so much unfold as steadily defibrillate
you...Bodies crumple; metal clangs; and anything
that doesn't get punched or shot or stabbed
on sight just stands by patiently, waiting
to explode.
When it's not all completely brain-numbing,
it's actually pretty fun."
It sounds like Brian Tallerico of RogerEbert.com
was perfectly content letting the film's kinetic
energy wash over him:
"What are audiences really here for?
They want some banter between stars Jason
Statham and Dwayne Johnson?
Check.
They want them to beat each other up a few
times?
Check.
A physics-defying car chase or two would be
nice?
Check and check."
Elsewhere in his review, Tallerico claimed,
"The truth is that the Summer of 2019 has
been ridiculously thin when it comes to mindless
fun.
And there's something to be said for merely
bouncing four movie stars as charismatic as
this film's quartet off each other for just
over two hours."
Cleveland Plain Dealer's Chuck Yarborough
was clearly a fan of the film, effusively
gushing that,
"[Hobbs & Shaw is] one of the most entertaining
action movies you'll see this year...What
makes this film work is the humor that pours
from Johnson, and what he’s able to elicit
from his fellow actors.
Particularly good are the insults in what
we used to call the 'slip fights' between
him and Statham."
Of course, plenty of critics walked away from
the film with a sour face, and there's no
shortage of snarky reviews out there.
Donald Clarke of the Irish Times sniped,
"After just half an hour, I was tempted to
spread foam across the screen and scrape off
the stubble that was already breaking through...The
awful banter is something else.
Neither man has, to be fair, much to work
with."
Jake Wilson of The Age unleashed plenty of
scorn on Morgan's screenplay and its plethora
of quips:
"The action regularly grinds to a halt so
[Hobbs and Shaw] can trade elaborate putdowns,
which give every sign of having been crafted
by writers whose practical experience of brawling
has occurred mostly on Twitter."
Keenly demonstrating how to effectively put
someone down, Wilson goes on say,
"For the leading men, everything appears to
be business as usual - which hardly needs
saying in the case of Statham, a cook who
knows just one dish."
Nevertheless, most critics were more than
willing to accept the film on its own terms.
Candice Frederick of The Wrap embraced the
absurdity of the blockbuster, writing that,
"[The film is] very cognizant of what it is,
which is also in line with what “Fast & Furious”
has always been: an opportunity for alpha
men (and women) to exchange insults then eventually
hug it out for the sake of some good old-fashioned
whoop-ass."
So that's what the critics had to say…now
it's time to make up your own mind.
Fast & Furious Presents: Hobbs & Shaw opens
on August 2nd…and we're expecting to be
electrified.
"Three shocks will kill a man."
"Here we go, it's a bad guy speech!"
"You had to open your big mouth, didn't ya,
huh?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.